was geht gerade ab alter mann mein name
ist luca und damit herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal meine lieben freunde der
korona virus ist das thema das uns
menschen in den letzten jahrzehnten wie
kein anderes beschäftigt von daher habe
ich mir gedacht ich nutze meine
reichweite um euch einen kleinen appell
mit zu geben day home das ist wirklich
das allerwichtigste in der jetzigen
situation also bitte überlegt euch zehn
mal ob ich jetzt noch in zwanzig
schulfreunden am park treffen müsste um
gegen sie zu stellen nur weil ihr
schulfrei haben das hat einen sinn das
alles mögliche geschlossen hat und sogar
schulen et cetera geschlossen sind jetzt
sicherlich schon von dem hashtag
glättende curve mitbekommen zwar geht es
dabei einfach darum dass man die
neuerkrankungen möglichst gering halten
will hier mal eine grafik dazu und zwar
muss man die kurve unter der kapazität
unseres gesundheitssystem halten dann
alle leute die jetzt eventuell sagen hey
ich bin jung gesund das corona virus
kann mir nichts anhaben ich bin quasi
unsterblich hier
ich bin jung deswegen juckt mich dass
kroner virus nicht ist der
zwillingsbruder von ich bin alt deswegen
ist mir der klimawandel egal wir sind
alle betroffen und gerade aufgrund der
aktuellen situation nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch der kompletten
erde müssen wir als menschen einfach
zusammenhalten und nicht nur an uns
denken sondern auch an unsere alten
schwachen und kranken menschen in der
gesellschaft und beim thema
zusammenhalten geht es nicht darum dass
man in den supermarkt lockt und die
70.000 rollen klopapier kaufen hat gott
verdammt apokalypse doch ich glaube ich
an egal war gestern abend ein kauf in
meinem revier und ich dir auch wirklich
um das nötigste zu kaufen alle termine
habe ich abgesagt ich versuche so weit
es geht zu hause zu bleiben telefoniere
täglich mit meinen liebsten mit meiner
familie cetera pp ich gehe raus was sehe
ich 20 schulkinder die da sitzen die da
irgendwie zocken die da irgendwie
tischtennis spielen dann kommen die an
und wollen foto ich war stocksauer wir
dem etwa instagram folgen dir heute
wahrscheinlich erst mal dieses
wundervolle bild hier von mir gepostet
gesehen allerdings habt ihr dann
wahrscheinlich auch meine story gesehen
und da habe ich gesagt dass ich heute
eigentlich auf mems zum corona virus
reagieren wollte dann habe ich
allerdings niemals rausgesucht und mir
ist immer mehr dabei aufgefallen
das thema ist nicht mehr zum lachen ich
selber habe vor einigen wochen noch ein
video dazu gemacht indem ich wirklich
tatkräftig bekräftige sprachen lernen
dass ich selber hat bereits vor einigen
wochen ein video zum corona virus
gemacht indem ich meine meinung und
meine sicht auf die ganzen dinge näher
gelegt habe allerdings war das aufgrund
der damals aktuellen faktenlage und
damals war es halt so dass
der korona virus ungefährlich war es
eine grippe die haben uns darüber alle
so ein bisschen lustig gemacht weil die
ganze panik aber jetzt ist es wirklich
ernst und ich muss mich wirklich
entschuldigen für einige aussagen die in
dem video damals getroffen habe
allerdings hat glaube ich niemand von
uns allen damit gerechnet dass es diese
ausmaße erlangen wird ich meinen unsere
wirtschaft ist zusammengebrochen wie
noch nie
und nicht nur das es wird über eine
ausgangssperre diskutiert
wird
leute
bitte bleibt zuhause und lasst es nicht
so weit kommen und dann alle leute die
jetzt kommentieren
luca du machst das video hier nur wegen
geld und wegen klicks auf youtube
monetarisiert videos mit dem corona wir
uns nicht also ich verdiene daran
absolut gar keinen euro in das mir um
geld gehen würde hätte ich heute dass
anderes hochgeladen aber mir geht es
einfach darum dass die leute mal bitte
vernunft wegen lassen sollen verfallen
nicht in hysterie verfallen nicht in
panik aber bitte fokussiert euch auf die
fakten und arbeitet mit einem normalen
menschenverstand und kauft euch nicht
70.000 packungen nudeln und nicht aus
hongkong open your parents bockholt yu
yongding cologna kraut you can't du
siehst ja unsere großeltern mussten in
den krieg ziehen und wir werden verdammt
noch mal dazu aufgerufen einfach nur zu
hause zu bleiben leute ihr könnt zocken
ihr könnt serien gucken wie ihr wollt
bitte bleibt zuhause stattdessen sich
solche bilder im internet wo leute
klopapier mit einem fahrradschloss einer
säule fest binden oder hier klopapier
abwägen wie drogen hier spielen sie
pokere mit klopapier hier blackjack und
hier lassen sie keine wertgegenstände
von außen sichtbar im fahrzeug liegen
gesagt die polizei und er lässt leute
was habt ihr mit diesem verdammten
klopapier und falls ihr tipps für die
quarantänezeit zu hause braucht hier
zwei videos von zwei leuten die die zeit
wirklich kreativ genutzt haben
[Musik]
es gibt sogar eine spotify corona
playlist und in der sind lieder wie
toxic mexiko mode anmelden stand so
close to me bleibe lieber zu hause macht
solche - und solche playlisten als dass
er nach draußen gehen und euch mit euren
freunden treffe weil das ist nicht der
sinn von quarantäne allerdings bringt
der korona virus nicht nur negatives mit
sich sondern schaut euch mal das hier an
das war chinas luftverschmutzung anfang
januar und das hier ist chinas
luftverschmutzung ende februar und das
hier beispielsweise ist ein bild von den
kanälen in venedig nach dem schottern
also das wasser ist wirklich glasklar
ja ich finde
dass man auch in sehr sehr sehr sehr
schlimmen zeiten in sehr dunklen zeiten
nie das licht am ende des tunnels
verlieren sollte
ich war dichter im mittelalter
allerdings möchte ich jetzt auch nicht
jahrelang über den corona virus lagern
ich glaube da sollte man lieber auf
unsere gesundheitsminister jens spahn
auf unsere bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
auf die whu vertrauen und unter anderem
auch noch auf wissenschaftliche experten
auf virologen es gibt zum beispiel in
coolen podcast von christian drosten das
ist ein virologe aus dem charité berlin
der informiert nahezu täglich über die
aktuellen veränderungen also das kann
ich euch auf jeden fall empfehlen von
links unten der video beschreibung meine
quintessenz aus dem heutigen video soll
einfach sein und ich möchte dass ihr
euch das wirklich zu herzen nehmen dass
ihr bitte zu hause bleibt
ich kann jetzt niemanden zwingen und
sagen hey schließt sich in einem zimmer
ein
aber das schlimmste was leute wirklich
machen könntest nach draußen gehen sich
mit freunden treffen schön noch mit der
s bahn nach hause fahren schön da alles
anfassen und dann die oma und opa
besuchen
also meine omas und opas leben eh alle
nicht mehr aber wenn wenn die noch am
leben
es ist einfach keine schöne situation
gerade und ich finde wir sollten alle
nicht nur an uns denken so wie menschen
das leider ziemlich häufig tun sondern
wirklich mal an unsere mitmenschen und
zu der aussage möchte ich auch noch mal
ganz kurz das thema hamsterkäufe
anschneiden ich habe absolut kein
verständnis dafür wenn junge gesunde
menschen jetzt meinen sich 80 packungen
nudeln zu kaufen 70.000 packungen reis
und eine million klopapierrollen leute
die grundversorgung bleibt gewährleistet
auch wenn es eine ausgangssperre gibt
darf man immer noch wege tätigen zur
arbeit zum supermarkt oder zur apotheke
und auch wenn die grenzen geschlossen
sind kommen dennoch lieferungen von
waren von lebensmitteln rein und raus
also es macht absolut gar keinen sinn
sich jetzt für eine isolation von
gefühlten 30 jahren was ich manche leute
dazu legen anzueignen wirklich benutzen
menschenverstand und ich möchte das
video mit diesem bild hier beenden
das ist eine technik wie ihr euch eure
hände waschen sollte das sieht jetzt
kompliziert aus weil das zwölf
verschiedene bilder sind aber macht euch
dieses bild einfach mal auf wenn ihr
euch das nächste mal die hände waschen
und ihr habt das nach ein zwei mal habt
ihr das unterbewusst drinnen diese
technik also macht euch hier gern
screenshot von und ich wird das video an
der stelle jetzt auch beenden ich habe
mich einfach danach gefühlt dass dieses
video vielleicht gerade richtig sei weil
ich habe mehr als 4 millionen abonnenten
und wenn ich sehe dass leute die
augenscheinlich fans von mir sind
sie ein foto mit mir machen wollten
draußen rumhängen möchte ich euch
einfach mit geben leute
bitte
ihr habt in eurem ganzen leben noch
genug zeit euch mit freunden zu treffen
bleibt zu hause
[Musik]